bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fabi j
oggi siamo su dio vivo un amico mio ti
sei lavato i capelli l'ultima volta la
madonna ha chiesto pressiamo la finanza
ok per un sogno
grazie a dio non sogno e de rossi in
mezzo al fuoco così a caso se la torcia
umana non sto capendo un caso maggiore o
niente ragazzi mi hanno
dove sono gli altri sono spariti tutti
siamo caduti in un qualcuno è stato
trascinato quindi direi che sono andati
di qua per forza però non so dove
ragazzi siamo partiti malissimo
non ho mai visto gioco partire così male
per ora non lo conosco no come non devo
non lo conosco perché non ti avvicinare
perché non lo fare non lo farà perché
dice ma che regala a coach anno nel
cervello i protagonisti degli horror ma
perché giorno che stai mangiando non
voglio sapere che cosa stai mangiando
perché te lo chiesa il back yard che
bella ma che poi posso unirmi a lei vara
io ho mangiato un po di cereali
stamattina è stata una genialata bravo
bravo bravo a vedi che lo conoscevano
non ero stupito
mangia
è la mano cos'è che schifo giorno bello
mio cosa siamo residenti voti su ca
gioca madonna che mira prodotta che ciò
che è morto è morto fantastici premi
cooper usa né ok posso s'accende da sola
proprio col pensiero non ho capito dove
stiamo andando
scortati al se proviamo questa una
trappola volevi avvisarmi di questo non
poliziotto forse posso aiutarti come
faccio a portarti in un ospedale
ospedali ma perché ce n'è una roba che
volteggia regal avete visto pedale
ecco io avrei reagito allo stesso modo
non è che è pazzo anch'io avrei fatto
così disarmare le trappole barasso al 7
ma chi è che mette le trappole che le
mette lo capitolo alta dove ha dato bari
dove non ti porta la spesa non sono un
deficiente se tranquilla ma per chi esce
una porta insanguinata ragazzi non
dovrei neanche entrarci si posi premi
c'è va bene lo shampoo giorno per me che
ci fa sta tizia qui ma perché noi esseri
umani normali entriamo negli specchi a
voi non vi capita mai la mattina quando
rispecchiate di testa dentro proprio
importante che lui sia contento poi
vabbè un'altra casa un altro specchio
ormai ragazzo io sono innamorato
buongiorno c'è un tizio che bussola
porta non sanno quale c'è il campanello
e cioè campanello non c'è bisogno di
silenzio ma perché devo uccidono colti e
non ha girato ma ragazzi mista vederlo
cazzo ma visto ragazzi non è perché sono
sexy quindi la gente vuole tipo
abbracciarmi ma io no ecco bravo zio
bravo stai fermo tolta e vedi di star
calmo perché arriva una pallottola to
some cassaforma chi è jackie chan stiz
l'alzata di gamba che minchia manco una
ballerina cazzo non mi toccare lurido
porco
ma no ma non ci ma [ __ ]
ma io gli ho sparato in faccia il suo
pranzo mio dio chi è quel rega
c'è un tizio che corso dentro all'area
terminati ma credo capito mac decidevo
silenziosamente ecco contro il più bello
e tragica sta cosa ma devo farlo perché
sono tra voi
fuori fuori cioè eccoli perfetto dove
non c'è il cervello amico mio di ragazzi
non ho capito perché devono bruciare la
gente non ha senso va bene c'è un team
c'è un tizio qua dentro che non voglio
andare a trovare perché mica go addosso
suo passare di qua no perché ci sono da
ragnatele quindi preferisco età è la
madonna non è un accendino quello è un
acido bruciato un corpo in 22 secondi
anche me giorno a è uscito da retta da
furbo lui ragazzo va da amico e
superstizioni prima perfetta ancora il
tutorial tra l'altro impossibile ragazzi
brucia tutto non è normale sacrati non
già un cancello che si chiude da solo
peter hayes di andarci dentro però va
bene entro proprio perché non c'è
nient'altro la fa
vabbè sentiti delle bottiglie da ci
fanno perché ci sono delle botti devo
già distrarre qualcuno sono convinto se
questo ragazze un tizio senta lei non è
che per caso lei a gentile visto che gli
alieni sono sette di queste parti quanto
zio non so quanti horror hai giocato su
però io che c'è un po più di esperienza
non si parla dei morti che camminano non
era cosa buona
i ragazzi ok quanto detto io scusa che
mangiare lo yogurt scaduto fasto effetto
c'è troppa gente [ __ ] il suo posto è che
posso ecco non devo combatterli pure
adesso ho capito che è stata la
bottiglia ci mancava solo questo ma se
io tipo gliela lancio in faccia di
prepotenza tipologia non l'ho preso con
sua somma visto non ha mai visto madonna
che stealth rega che è stealth in due
secondi sono io non si è popolato sto
posto non so non so proiettili non c'è
un cazzo cosa le lattine mio dio cioè io
gli sto gioco vado vado avanti a lattine
non so se è normale dove devo andare
idea di là non vado dall'altra parte va
via via via via via via via via via via
via via veloce veloce e vabbè io corro
perché tanto sei tu che puoi coltissimo
ricerche in cui quel ragazzo li che e
mio amico merda no no no no no no no no
no però è ma che forma donna che mira di
merda che c'è un pivot riuscito a
mancarlo da un metro e incredibile che
ancora attaccapanni costo pari a circa
20 io vado
cazzo e not deve entrare in casa no non
mi morire così
non mi va di casa brucia più resistenza
a lui che è uno zombie ma si può merda
veloce veloce ecco bravo possibilmente
chiudi adesso non aprono le porte esiste
non si vergogna non si hanno perduto la
chiazza è peggiorato lo senti buonuomo
gli aiuti non mi aiuta nessuno in questi
piccoli fate voi
qualcosa mi dice che ho sbagliato strada
ma se già faccio già faccio ci faccio
qui devi morire si madonna quanto godo
quanto quanto ho fatto piatta a capanni
di quanto non lo fossi già privo trovate
una torcia che non so che cosa me ne
faccio prova tanto c'è la lanterna ma
lanterna della madonna prio la torcia
marioni proietti grazie a due proiettili
a buongiorno sono tornato che i
proiettili dello stronzo est ha voltato
anche preso ascoltami e si sente più
bello di prima è questo come uragano
muore
no ragazzi non può niente 6 anche più
bello così non era un proiettile un
bazooka sto coso cioè non si può fare un
cazzo di m che c'è gente ovunque dato
come fa non vede invece una trave in
testa fosse già faccio la faccio non so
perché dice veramente troppo agenti sto
gioco ce la possa fare un metro mi è
venuta un'idea ma non so quanto può
funzionare aspetta aspetta un attimo
appello di zio mi vedi bravo che sia la
strada da seguire
forse passa in mezzo tra può già fi
chapa chapa chapa chapa sorgerà funzione
una volta che faccio qualcosa che serve
la prima in assoluto sul telefono tutte
idee che ciò nei giochi in genere non
funzionano un cazzo ma questa ha
funzionato non si sa perché lontani
comino vini di quadrati e girati per
favore jia jia il bravo ecco proprio
seguimi senti qua di qua barak e bella
torta guarda che bella torta bravo così
non c'era nessuno
è che cos'è ragazzi no no no no
si vabbè ma sergente frutta ma dietro a
tema così stuprano ragazzi è svenuto ha
pianto
veloce veloce veloce la lazio alloggio
veloce ma per moriamo minchia dai cazzo
io sono morto un uomo morto ma veloce
sono esplosi tutti lo zio di morire i
cuori di chi sa cosa nostro progetto
ragazzi
guardo a bordo ma tantaro tanta roba no
io questa è stata l'azione più bella
della storia ragazzi non c'e non ce la
faccio ad aprire quel ponte senza che
questi tizi si alzi mi occupo di sparo
prima che che si alzi non si può fare ma
ecco infatti altro assistenza brutto
stronzo e muore si alza ma basta
ma basta stai a terra non posso andare
io ve lo dico non possa andare avanti
così mi fanno alcuno veloce e ansia che
tra chi ha la visuale perfetto ma mi ha
visto nei suoi grazie a dio pagano io io
non posso fare io voglio io voglio
capire voglio capire quel tizio che
stavo in quel mio amico dove è andato a
film come ha fatto a passare il suo
punto non è possibile coltivare maria in
stato illegale quindi vi denuncio ma
finché si fumano la maria tra di loro va
bene così
ma visto ancora adesso mi ha visto cazzo
non i quali come panucci passa e va
benissimo
non c'è veloce cos'è il concerto di
guardare se riuscissi a correre più di
un metro
niente che sia tutto
porca [ __ ] dovevano andare così lisa
si sa che l'hanno fatto apposta
certo che è la madonna mercato posso
sempre ragazzino che siamo tutti i
jackie chan
perché ragazzi al taglio
e una bimba in confronto mezzo morto
tipo va bene siamo risalti ragazzi da
wanda un lago e caso che ti può non
farlo dall'inizio di buco nell'acqua e
mi facevo tutto livello in mare sarebbe
stato meglio dove è fatemi capire il
corpo lo sapevo linz parolo prima una
ragazza ne andiamo avanti e non
facciamoci domande perché ancora e mi
stavi più cura di pazienza e che ha
trovato una una forza nata una ragazza
bomba ma non ama certo è un classico
vedere dayco dei cordi con delle bombe a
mano addosso trovare di proiettile capo
che non so più un cazzo di proiettile
giorno la zona visto all'asca scarica e
proprio cielo chi è che ha aperto la
porta così scoperto i nostri amici si va
beh ma si aprono porte crolla tutto a
casa dessì affinity richiama la donna e
questo è il paese dei balocchi per caso
sono nel posto giusto
scott azionate perché sono della sala
giochi sto posto perché devo divertire
no eh vabbè allora ti brucia perché
quelli che non mi danno indicazioni mi
stanno sul pool abbiate pazienza
ragazzi ma è normale che si aprono le
porte a caso non ci dovrei neanche
entrare in un posto dove si apre la
porta da sola e si chiude da solo ci
avrà un sensore sarà che c'è una mannaia
trovato la mamma donna adesso faccio io
lo avrei scommesso che sarebbe stato per
me ne sono accorto troppo tardi ragazzi
c'è qualcosa che continua non tornare
come mai se non ci sono ragazzi è la ix
spari
no no stai tranquillo che scarica se
sono un dottore marcelo jimenez arresto
a qualcun altro
il mio paziente a leslie l'ho visto
scappare via ma si dice l'ambulanza
questo l'incidentato qua allora fammi
capire e amico renato letti dai stesso a
di quelle cose mi hanno inseguito fin
dentro il villaggio anche a me quanto
sono belle e brave non è che non è che
sono easley è entrato l'attrice come ha
fatto apposta concentrata passare
st.james alcuno di noi li deve attirare
lontana l'altro aprirà il cancello
indovina chi è che li deve attirare
lontano euro con grande matteo se ti
dicessi che scarica e ti prendo a calci
nel culo non proietti il cazzo come
faccio
sono qui esatto di qua
avete presente la demenza posiziona la
rappresenta ragazzino non so se quel
tizio e cazzo no no no no no no no no
devi morire è la madonna che botta
veloce rozzo e mi caga sono solo morto
praticamente morto non ce la farò ma è
la madonna e quanta gente c'è scottate
sezione ragazzi e non ciò che non son
[ __ ] cosa devo trovare un riparo
merda veloce veloce lasciano mitigare
diano miglia come figlia non mi piglia
non preso è la faccio adesso ce la
faccio devi morire non manca farlo
presente compreso
porca [ __ ] non è possibile come
faccio a finire ogni volta i colpi 4
secondi tira i temi che si apre la porta
di ok ragazzi capiscano di 3.000
coltelli in faccia verranno questo tipo
ragazzi ci troviamo se gesù spera
speravo che fosse questo come i
residenti voci lacan nicchia cattivo
ragazzo adesso son cazzi loro se per
caso qualcuno mica mi arriva davanti lo
sono molecole o un giorno signora
scarpinato invaghiti ecco perfetto le
piace mercato a pronti come diavolo
faccio ad aprirlo
ma dai è una domanda che ho fatto io il
giusto un secondo fa ma chi è questo c'è
un fucile il cazzo ha fatto il fucile in
mano un fucile rega non è normale da
chiara da ragazzi per oggi concluso qui
perché è stato è veramente alimentando
tragico sto già tragico anche ragazzi se
il video mi è piaciuto ma se hai
lasciato un commento mi piace anche a
causa di facebook e come non glie lo
trovate nella descrizione sera siete
vorresti discutere ci rivediamo il
prossimo vita delle ragazze